liz truss grew up here in leeds she says
she's a plain speaking yorkshire woman
she's been described as a human hand
grenade but who is our new prime
minister
before we go on make sure you subscribe
to our sky news youtube channel for more
analysis and explainer content hit the
button below born to left-wing parents
in oxford she moved to paisley near
glasgow as a young child but liz trust
says her political awakening came at
secondary school in leeds here at round
hey school she says children were failed
and let down by low expectations
while we were taught about racism and
sexism it was too little time spent
making sure everyone could read and
write i i was a year behind liz trust
and the only memories i've really got of
this school are all positive there's a
lot of frustration and anger around here
in round day because you know this this
school um you know effectively has
helped liz trust on her career
liz truss hasn't always been a
conservative after leaving this school
in leeds she headed to oxford university
to study politics philosophy and
economics and became president of the
student liberal democrats
but before she left university liz trust
had switched to the conservatives he's
an absolutely excellent candidate um and
uh i very much hope she'll be the
candidate she stood as an mp twice in
2001 and 2005 but was unsuccessful
she eventually won a tory safe seat in
norfolk in 2010 despite a battle with
her local party for not declaring an
affair with a married conservative mp by
2014 she was environment secretary i'm
absolutely delighted to be reappointing
this job it's a vital role and she
served in five cabinet posts i'm
delighted to be appointed as secretary
of state for justice including as
foreign secretary thank you very much
thank you to be honest there's no way
you can't notice liz she's got so much
energy she's got so much enthusiasm most
people were using their social media for
fairly standard kind of visits hard hats
helmets that kind of stuff whereas she
was going to big fashion retailers and
um not just thinking about kind of how
she looks but also how she could kind of
curate really fun visits around her and
establish herself as like a bit of
minister of fun and you saw that
sometimes in cabinets she would turn up
in leather jackets
she wouldn't necessarily be wearing kind
of the same tweed blazers as everyone
else despite campaigning against brexit
in recent months she's become the
darling of the right wing of the
conservative party she's promised to cut
taxes fight wokeness in the civil
service and has railed against
government handouts very ideological
person she has a very clear sense of the
broad political
approaches that she believes in i don't
think our government's role should be
tell us to tell us what tastes we should
have
too often we're told we're drinking too
much or maybe that's just me
does have this tendency almost to behave
when she's in dialogue with you as if
she has a hearing problem that she can't
hear the case that you're putting that
she can't hear when you're trying to uh
interrupt her and intervene she just
takes her position and she sort of plows
on and on and on
as if she's not really listening to uh
to the argument she's getting from other
people she's come a long way since this
speech that the internet won't let her
forget
we import two-thirds of our
cheese that is a disgrace
in december i'll be in beijing
opening up new pork markets
loyal to boris johnson inspired by
margaret thatcher she only has two years
until the next election to show whether
she can be a winner
[Music]